why do women celebrate the wrong thing
but I don't think it's just women like
where did this whole thing about just
women glorifying something because I
think if anything men do the same thing
just going back to the reference that
you just gave about drug dealers or
whatever that's the whole popular
culture right now everybody loves rap
music everybody is mimicking rappers
talking about things they don't know
what the rappers are talking about
that's literally the wave so I'm not
going to agree with you on the fact that
only women glorify I mean women they do
it for the audience women women no no
you're from Atlanta that's like
especially like no women make 80 because
there's a lot of high earning women in
Atlanta no I understand yeah so so women
make 80% of consumer buying decisions so
the stuff you see in the music the stuff
you see on TV it's catered to women